hey everyone what's up welcome back to
day five of css3 in 30 days today we're
going to be building something super
simple and super easy but it's really
really meaningful and can really kind of
take your websites or your applications
to the next level when it comes to user
experience now let me show you what I
mean jump over here into my browser
we're gonna do something called useful
broken images now whether it's a typo in
the image tag source or the image tag
itself was misplaced or removed on the
server images break all the time on the
web the problem is the browser's default
way to display a broken image is
typically pretty darn ugly you know
where you have that little like
screenshot it shows like a little image
thumbnail with like a crack through the
middle or a rip and it just it's a
broken image icon and it doesn't look
very good sometimes it's just the
browser's default way of displaying that
kind of looks bad you can fix that
however and actually use it as an
opportunity to enhance the users
experience on your webpages with CSS now
that's your challenge this lesson so you
kind of take you know when websites
throw you lemons you create lemonade
right so we're gonna be creating useful
broken images let me show you this is a
standard broken image it cannot find
this image on purpose i coded it
improperly so it's finding an image that
is not located from the server anywhere
this is what it looks like
looks terrible and makes you look bad
but if you scroll down here check this
out flying eagle not found with a nice
little icon a camera with an X and then
a nice dotted line around it it's just
it looks nicer now the image isn't there
so that sucks but it's pulling in
information and notifying the user of
what happened this is a much more fluid
and positive user experience let's find
out how to code that right now shall we
over here in our code editor I have my
number five useful broken images course
files go ahead and download that it's in
this module you could click to download
it it'll to give you a Dropbox link
something really simple so you could
download the useful broken images and
index is the markup it's very simple all
it is is an image tag with NOAA with no
image there so there's no image in the
server called bro
an image I did it on purpose and then an
alt attribute that's important because
we're going to be using that in CSS
that's all it is
sandbox is where we're going to be
coding up our far styles and final is
the final result so let's go ahead and
do that code our Styles right here first
thing we're going to be doing is
selecting a class just called image not
going to just select the image tag but I
just wanted to do it this way and we're
gonna say position:relative the display
will be inline block the font size let's
do something like 0.7 rim
text-align:center text ants form
uppercase and save now if we head over
to our browser you're gonna see here it
that it's changed the default style of
the broken image now I want to make that
font size a little bit bigger so I'm
actually just gonna say one rim and that
should make it the default size I like
that okay and now we're gonna do this is
easy we're almost done
image the after pseudo element we're
gonna say display inherit so we're gonna
inherit the inline block style we're
gonna position:absolute top:0 left:0
we're gonna do width 100% min width it's
gonna be a minimum of 200 pixels padding
will be 10 20 10 and 45 to account for
the icon that we're gonna put on the
left side we're gonna go border all we
need a semicolon up here that's why
border dashed dashed one pixel
triple-eight and then we're gonna say
background color is going to be F 0 F 0
F 0 and then the background image we're
gonna pull that URL called no image dot
PNG right here in our useful broken
images folder directory background size
for that image it was gonna be 10%
background-repeat:no-repeat background
the 10 pixels on the Y is n index 1 and
the content this is gonna be cool so I'm
gonna save that actually save so far and
see what we have now you can see there's
nothing there we did all these thousand
nothing showed up that's because we
didn't do the content property yet so
you always have to do content on an
after or before pseudo-element back here
in the code editor simple we could do
something like content 2 empty string
now if we head back you'll see that
something is appearing but it's this
obviously doesn't look very good so
we're going to fix that by adding text
within that element and we're gonna
we're gonna adjust that so so here in
content we're going to do the double
string and then right after that we're
gonna say attribute so it's the
attribute value for the content property
and we're gonna say alt so what's that
doing it's so looking for the HTML
attribute alt the value of it so here
the alt flying eagle so it's looking for
that attribute alt so it's going to grab
that value and put it as the content and
then after that another string to close
one double string to close that previous
one and then not found and then close
the string one more time so how is this
work so we have an open double string
which closes over here but we also have
another set of strings in here that wrap
around the attribute alt so it's just
something that we kind of have to do
it's like concatenating
the text so attribute alt so the alt
text not found save that go over here to
a browser check it out flying eagle not
found we got that icon from our useful
broken images directory nice and now if
we had a different image let's go to our
index and I'm just gonna add another
image here and say broken image to and
change the alt text to like let's just
say paddleboard and then I'm gonna put a
break tag save that check it out in the
browser so a paddleboard not found now
they're stacking on top of each other
the reason why that's happening is
because these are the after pseudo
elements the actual image itself so if I
inspect this the image itself is is this
large and then the after pseudo element
is that size so the image they're
actually stacking on top of each other
perfectly
but it's the after pseudo element that's
conflicting so we just give the image
some space around it so here I'm just
going to say margin images will have
a margin of 0-0 40 pixels and then that
should solve the problem there we go so
over here we got some space nice looks
great
so that is day five useful broken images
that's all we had to do is really simple
but very powerful because hey it's nice
to have a nicer user experience and we
can do that with our broken images so
you didn't maybe you didn't know that
you could do that that's a pretty cool
trick that's useful in your web
development and your your portfolio your
website apps of applications client
sites so hopefully you enjoyed the
useful broken images lesson hang tight
for tomorrow we're gonna do day six and
we got some more fun stuff to code up in
CSS I'll catch you there bye now
[Music]